freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge einen tag persönlicher
koch eine ganz besondere folge wie ich
finde denn heute ist lukas zu gast
kommen gerne ins bild mein lieber rücken
das gestern abend schon kennenlernen und
habe eine gute zeit das ist ein relikt
von gestern abend wahrscheinlich dass
ein kleines gastgeschenk des
jugendlichen sehr aufmerksam und macht
macht nicht jeder weiß ich schon mal
sehr zu schätzen aber auch ein geschenk
für dich und die anfänge davon zeigt
hier schon wir haben da viel schönes
sauerteigbrot und alles was im beef
tatar benötigt deshalb man lieber lukas
machst dir gemütlich schwingt den
kochlöffel nicht immer gleich eigentlich
fast die küche kalt was er richtig schön
anfällig und sehen uns gleich zum
frühstück und dann machen vielleicht ja
schon okay bin zuallererst bearbeite ich
meine rosa flesch ich habe hier so ein
sehr sehr schönes australisches leben im
jahr beziehungsweise gleich zwei stück
davon geholt wichtig wir schneiden das
ganze jetzt gegen die phase also hier
seht ihr läuft quasi einmal die phase
durch wir schneiden das ganze aber so
dadurch ist es einfach viel zarter und
natürlich ganz wichtig weil kaka bleibt
das fleisch muss eine ganz vorbild haben
aber das ist sicher sein habe ich mich
nicht lumpen lassen wir schneiden das
ganze jetzt in etwa fünf millimeter
breite scheiben und jetzt wenn das ganze
so haben schneiden wir uns noch in
streifen
und dann hab ich mir so eine schüssel
gestellt bei hier passiert gleich dann
die hochzeit von allen zutaten unser
fahrer aus machen wird ist auch ganz
schön anzusehen macht das jetzt erstmal
mit ein da sehen wir sogleich wieder so
dass bio ist geschnitten jetzt machen
wir weiter mit unseren zwiebeln
beziehungsweise in unseren schalotten
hier ist jetzt wirklich die oberste
prämisse alles so fein wie es nur geht
zu schneiden das ist ja etwas sehr edles
und irgendwann muss man auch feststellen
das was jetzt noch reinkommen kommen
chance charlotten wie auch immer endlich
richtig schön fallen
selbst damit bin ich zufrieden
jetzt noch viermal aber sehr sehr gut
aus ich wohne sind ein logischer
bekommen das gleiche machen wir jetzt
mit cornish aber extra französische
geholt also die kleinen gleiche
geschichte
darüber als nächstes schnell wie ein
bisschen schnittlauch und petersilie
anshu jain zwei stück ihr könnt es
wahrscheinlich schon raten auch das
packen wir jetzt wieder fein so das muss
weiß auch hierzu und jetzt haben wir uns
ein ordentlicher vier cent in die mitte
mit darin einen kleinen pool wie mir das
geld nämlich nur in die mitte insgesamt
wenig olivenöl und guter letzt ein zwei
specials von der berühmten
leute es wird zeit für die hochzeit alle
zutaten werden jetzt vermengt einfach
alles zusammen ziehen und vielleicht
noch ein bisschen sieht schon da drin so
sei der essent das kommt alles schön
zusammen verlocken dazu dass mir das
ganze gleich kurz stehen die nicht
verkehrt aus
[Musik]
ja wir sind immer noch geprüft würde
immer noch flüchtig dazu schon so herbst
wollen wir deinen er mitbringen zu
eröffnen dann natürlich zu schade aber
ich habe fehler weise auch noch was
offen als in wien lebender mensch ist es
natürlich absolute star er hat das pro
jahr muss sein also auf den ersten blick
auf ihren war wunderschön ich muss sagen
ich habe mich vertan nie so angeregt
bekommen und noch nie so gegessen auf
den ersten blick wie die st rustikale
interpretation eines eines quartals vor
allem die das fleisch ist ein bisschen
dicke geschnitten auch mit dem
sauerteigbrot anstatt diese ist was man
klassischerweise hat dieses hätte dieses
weissbrodt trost dementsprechend auch
auf dem holzbrett angerichtet man sieht
ein bisschen größeren oder die
entscheidung geschnitten wurden da sie
aber sieht schon sehr lecker aus schon
direkt das könne keiner magath kann man
das schon viel zu essen gesagt und hat
hier immer noch viel zu essen zu sagen
ist es mal mit butter problem da sieht
man auch schon so viel salz darüber
gestreut auf jeden fall sehr viel liebe
zu begleiten
auf dem mond selbst verstand
poker face ist auf jeden fall da
das war so richtig dieser sound
ist finde ich sehr sehr gut deshalb
genießt das ganze und wir sehen uns
gleich zu bewerten
das brettchen ist leer das ist schon mal
gut ich hoffe es hat ja auch geschmeckt
es war sehr lecker damit schon mal der
die ärzte sorge schon mal weg ich habe
auch ein bisschen gegessen ich kann es
auch nicht verkehrt ich will gar nicht
viel sagen weil du sollst ja heute alles
klar es war sehr lecker muss man muss
man so sagen auch wenn für ein frühstück
sowas traum frühstück so wie es mir auch
vorgestellt haben frühstück für könige
beim sekt dazu sagen das brot genial so
ist man perfekt ausgewählt auch perfekt
angeboten muss man sagen es war genauso
leicht weich und ausnahmslos schöne
olivenöl groß wie ich auch ford schon
gesagt das ist war so ein bisschen ich
würde sagen rustikale rente
interpretation eines eines bestatters
aussetzung persönlichen geschmack nicht
100% treffen dabei versuchen natürlich
trotzdem professionell bis zu betrachten
professionell zu bewerten sowohl über
geschnitten ich würde sagen das ist
wahrscheinlich auf einer lieber gerade
hätte der fonds trockenen grund da so
ein bisschen die zutaten mehr
zusammenfinden und dem löffel gleich
viel wert sein die gurke kleinen
bestimmten alles sehr klein gestellt hat
ist einfach auf einem löffel so ich
denke dass volljährige max erlebnis als
wenn es robusten hast du mal stücke von
dort ein stück von dort aber das ist
halt auch geschmack sie also sagen dass
alles eingerechnet würde ich sagen ich
gebe eine 8,9 8,9
hatten wir glaube ich auch noch nicht
das ist sehr differenziert und auch sehr
gut also ich fühle was du sagst ich habe
heute ein rezept gesehen dass es für gut
befunden habe das ein bisschen dicker
bestimmt nicht wäre wahrscheinlich
selbst auch überhaupt nicht abgeneigt
davon beziehungsweise fans vielleicht
auch sogar geil wenn es noch ein
bisschen kleiner lehre dass er bin ich
voll bei direkten brot kann ich keine
qualität verlieren aber das ist halt
immer im blick so gewann brach ich hab's
eine weiter aber was recht aber noch
luft nach oben kommen nur ins hammer
deshalb häufig trotzdem noch steigern
kann beim mittagessen es gibt nämlich
cuturi people und nicht irgendwie
sondern mit trüffel wir machen kein
tattoo vor oder partout vater oder
irgendwas auf jeden fall wo ich ein
bisschen trüffel mit eingeworfen habe
ich hoffentlich hoffentlich lukas
beeindruckenden überzeugen kann wir
haben packen fertige ich habe überlegt
mache ich frische pasta ich habe mich
dagegen entschieden verschiedene gründe
zum einen die pasta kocht länger
brauchen die stärke der nudel wasser die
gibt die stärker ab und das tut unserer
soße jeden fall gut um anderen die haben
eine raue oberfläche wodurch die soße
noch besser grunde und alles in allem
eigentlichen sehr leckeres pasta
erlebnis werden zu viel schnee wie du es
einfach aber für perfektion muss vieles
gut laufen deshalb werde ich möchte
gerne lukas heute auf jeden fall
überzeugt jetzt habe ich hier schon ein
bisschen schwarzem pfeffer vor gemalt
damit wollen wir auf jeden fall nicht
geizen um den ketscher unseren käse
kümmern wir uns auf jeden fall jetzt
altes spiel bereiten den gibt nicht viel
zu erzählen aus welchem käse es sich
handelt das hier ist corino romano
derart asse ist ein paar muss also nur
48 monate greift also mit noch mehr
geschmack keine genaue mengenangaben
keine gramzow wir werden sowieso gleich
am ende so ein bisschen trocken und
probieren dass wir irgendwie das
perfekte ergebnis erreichen deshalb fand
ja noch ein bisschen grün das gleiche
mache ich jetzt mit dem parmesan das
nudelwasser kocht das heißt wir können
so passt hinein gehen ich werde die
pasta in kleinen patches kochen also
nicht alles auf einmal sondern eben
genug für eine großzügige portion
für 13 minuten die eigentliche hochzeit
sind 16 also 340 das ganze um sie dann
hier in der pfanne fertig zu machen
stellt die noch nicht anderen fünf
minuten dann sehen wir uns nicht einmal
spannende überleitung seid ihr bereit
macht des ölreichen
gerade bei chelsea darf nicht geizt
nicht mit käse nicht miterleben will
dann geben wir hinein
das ist natürlich nicht nämlich
reindenken eine kleinere portion aber
das tabu themen für eine präsente väter
note haben er aus und spielen wir jetzt
schon das nudelwasser damit kommt
das ist jetzt ganz wertvoll für uns der
hauptkommissar vorbei darauf basieren
wir dürfen jetzt geht hier noch mal
nicht die folk mit erhitze frau den
traditionen flüssigkeit drin der
schutzbrief bildschirm und das sieht
schon gar nicht heraus sind nicht mal
ein bisschen runter mit der temperatur
einen menschen mit urin und braucht
bisschen mehr parmesan dann geht's mit
dem steht geht es jetzt darum die
flüssigkeiten ein bisschen raus zu
reduzieren große zu finden also das so
schön legte soße wird trifft note liegt
in der luft auf jeden fall schon jetzt
in schwarzem trüffel
ich würde lügen welche seite ein
bisschen ins schwitzen gekommen bin es
lief nicht alles nach plan irgendwie ist
der käse mit dem nudelwasser nicht so
perfekt ist und effekte mit geworden
wenn ich mir den telefonisch erreichen
mich zufrieden du als kaffeeliebhaber
von einer eingemeindung ja ich würde
auch lügen wenn ich sagen würde dass bei
mir in der küche nicht anders wenn ich
passt da besser sein timing sei es muss
dann einfach sitzen das raus was uns
dazu schnell schnell schnell die soße
musste käme werden ist immer action
immer eine explosion auch bei mir ja
sieht auf jeden fall sehr schöner und
vor allem auch der kontrast zwischen den
schwarzen trüffeln und drüber dekadenter
tag ein bisschen wie tartar ist sind
treffe man lässt diskutieren ja gerne
doch probieren bevor auch die nudel
sorte sehr gut gewählt sodass das schön
fläche damit die nudel greifen kann er
damit die soße greifen kann um die model
mama die auf hilfen schon so eine schöne
geschichte ich mir einmal
aber mit sehr sehr guten zutaten modell
gearbeitet ihre forschung sehen
pokerface nach wie vor sehen uns gleich
wenn der teller leer gefegt ist
hoffentlich dann gibt es für bewertungen
ich bin ein bisschen im zwiespalt muss
ich sagen das ist vielleicht von
wegnimmt und aufgegessen es war sehr
lecker und ist auch ein bisschen das
problem so es war sehr lecker ist so gut
geschmeckt und der der trüffel kommen
durch und salz und pfeffer hat gepasst
so überragt technisch betrachtet es halt
die soße ein bisschen krebs hat nicht
wirklich zusammen von astana war so ein
bisschen man sieht hier auch jetzt
gerade noch so ein bisschen so du hast
hier den käse und barrakudas werden
perfekt
zusammen jetzt hat die soße also voll
zusammengefunden die cremigkeit hat ein
bisschen gefehlt und zwar nicht so dass
osm schlank um die mehrheit werde erst
einmal trotzdem wenn du gestern hast was
hat lecker so da kann man halt nichts
dagegen sagen deswegen bin ich so ein
bisschen im zwiespalt aber ich glaube
alles in allem durch eine 8,1 du bist
wirklich der mann der der faszinierende
bewertung ich meine 8,1 ist ja immer
noch so voll gut so deshalb bin ich da
sehr froh darüber aber ich weiß es sehr
zu schätzen hast du so gute kritik gibt
es war heute morgen wie auch jetzt fühle
ich komplett was du sagt dass das nicht
so die perfekte creme geworden ist so
dass das habe ich auch selbst gestört
wenn es vielleicht nach den seiten hat
das nicht so gut notiert aber danke für
deine bewertung und heute abend
da kann alles passieren
was hast du denn gewünscht dass man
schon sagen du darfst du sagen aus
biblischen stoff sondern eine kleine
challenge werden und das auf jeden fall
also legen wir das ganz genau ihr habt
das gehört usbekischer klopp steht auf
der speisekarte
und ich habe es halt einfach noch nie
gemacht so ich habe mir einiges an
videos angeschaut unter anderem lukas
video wo tante stella das ganze gekauft
hat an und für sich ist das gar nicht so
unfassbar schwierig wir sollten das
eigentlich hinbekommen wir machen das
ganz entspannt ich habe mich ein
bisschen beruhigt vom mittagessen die
vorbereitung erst mal fertig indem wir
zwiebeln rote und weiße erstmal
einschneidend dazu gehört noch schneiden
darf ein bisschen größer sein mögen
kommen auch rein und die schneidig der
länge nach wie nennen wir diese korrekt
verhalten so sieht das ganze geschnitten
ausmache jetzt gehört in topf heißt
lieber ein bisschen hitzebeständiges ein
bisschen meine ich ein bisschen viel
hier vorne haben wir jetzt kalt und
lammfleisch habe so viel das ist in so
schönen bedecken wird schon direkt auf
temperatur gegeben dass jetzt rein
so soll das ganze aussehen ich weiß ja
nicht ob die richtigkeit denn das einmal
durchdacht ist weist nach oben dran sind
geben wir die zwiebeln die mögen dazu
gaben die aufträge eigentlich angenehme
sache jetzt gehen wir die zwiebel
nationen
rief man das hört man sieht man das
liebt man das wirklich entspannend finde
ich vom gerät zu pochen auf bewertungen
manchmal noch nie gemacht oder gegessen
haben es ist ein intuitives gericht
irgendwie so wie du brauchst einfach
zwei diebe so sehen und zwiebeln jetzt
aus und meint auch dass wir sagt mir
jetzt ist ein guter zeitpunkt für die
möhren übrigens wir machen das gerade
alles auf alle allerdings das fängt
gerade an so ein bisschen karamellisiert
zu riechen aber dass ein guter zeitpunkt
für uns um wasser
khroma wird zu dieser fettfilm der
direkten ist als ob das schon so drei
stunden lange köcheln wird und jetzt
reduzieren wir auch direkte jetzt geben
wir jetzt so ein hype stündchen und dann
geht's weiter mit dem nächsten schritt
was wird das video wirklich eine stunde
ist vergangen das reicht schon eine
schöne texte ich habe danach probierte
mit bisschen sei es angegangen und jetzt
geht noch ein bisschen kümmel dazu
einfach gemahlenem kreuzkümmel ich finde
das macht für mich immer so eine
besondere note auch türkische oder
arabische küche so ein bisschen können
wir dann dieses captain eine süße von
den möhren ich nicht erwartet hätte aber
die metro sinn macht ich mache gerade
vielleicht braucht auf jeden fall mache
ich etwas was sehr lecker und jetzt
haben wir die nächste geschmacks kommen
und zwar knoblauch eine ganze knolle und
noch vereinzelte 10 wichtig ist dass man
ein paar bolt langkornreis hat er sonst
verkocht geben denn jetzt einfach hier
über ich habe mehrmals gewaschen teilen
das ganze hier ein bisschen eine letzte
sache gehen wir noch dazu nämlich ein
paar chillig grüne boote waren jetzt ein
bisschen mit durch habe die hoffnung
dass es nicht allzu scharf sein wird wir
sehen uns in 30 minuten und dann sollten
wir auch schon essen können so sieht das
ganze aus schön flott nur ein bisschen
ich suche jetzt die schönsten stückchen
fleisch aus wäre ich natürlich den gast
geben und möchte dann mit ein bisschen
frühlingszwiebel mit ein bisschen
koriander und zitronen spalten einen
teller
[Musik]
schauen wir mal ich kann versprechen
dass hier gekocht er ist wirklich ein
langer zeit geht zu ende ich muss sagen
ich habe mir nicht überlegt so was
könnte kohl seinen drei speisen diese
bisschen abwechslungsreich sind die
vielleicht etwas neues dabei was man
noch nicht so kann gericht aus weiler
top muss auch dazu sagen es habe ich die
auch schon gesagt dass wir die speise
sein die ich am wenigsten professionell
bewerten kann weil ich sie noch nicht
sehr oft gegessen habe aber wenn ich sie
gestern war es immer ein schöner moment
sieht wunderschön aus das passt einfach
sein dankeschön proportionen passe nicht
noch jemand der so ein bisschen darauf
achtet wie ist das verhältnis von teller
größe zum inhalt und busters und passen
die proportionen und seine grüne eine
eine rote paprika unterseite die zitrone
auf jeden fall gut erkennbar länglich
geschnitten und die frühlingszwiebeln
sind für mich das was diese speise
nochmal um einiges länger aussehen lässt
aus den sieben nicht drauf sind wir
sehen erst im letzten moment aus dem
kühlschrank gekommen ein aufatmen gehört
denn du kannst ihren verstand die ganze
seite nach
schon schon eine interessante art und
weise für mich für dieses gericht dass
man so in der brühe die man so selbst
erstmal herstellt den reis kocht und
dann natürlich das fleisch darin guard
ist schon
was sagt ihr geschmack
also ich liebe ja
das hat das ist auch alles was wir
wissen ist bevor werden die pause gehen
aber wir sehen uns ja direkt wieder zur
bewertung
aufgegessen ich habe das erste mal
aufgegessen und notebook ich muss verrät
schon fast dir danke sagen dass du es
dir gewünscht hat 12 das war wirklich
ein neues rezept dass mein horizont
erweitert hat aber um eine sehr sehr
schöne sache sieht man die welt mit
anderen augen wirklich irre ich habe
auch gedacht so ich war ein teil von mir
also das herz der falter aber ich
verstehe man muss sagen die zutaten auch
wieder bauen auch die kombination auch
die zitrone zur ausgemacht habe die
folgen gar nicht gesehen aber wenn der
zitrone darüber gibt es hat noch mal
auch nur alles verändert ganze gesagt
wie nicht so gut gepasst aber es war
extrem lecker also ich glaube das ist
auch dass wenn man den
schwierigkeitsgrad mit einrechnen was du
heute am besten macht das einzige was
vielleicht noch hätte besser sein können
ich glaube es hätte noch ein bisschen
mehr reduzieren müssen wenn es noch
reduzierter gewesen wäre dann zum
intensiver glaube dass das für
diejenigen dies reduziert haben man
macht vielleicht die 30 minuten die
hälfte mit die andere hälfte oben decke
aber abgesehen davon kriegst du eine
neue die magische die magische barriere
durch geil da bin ich bin ich froh bin
ich erleichtert zum einen weiß welchen
bereichen und ist zum anwalt und ende
noch mal gas geben konnte du kannst das
war wirklich eine freude
es hat sehr viel spaß gemacht und ich
freue mich auch die tak morgen mit jetzt
verbringt weiß nicht wann ihr sehen
werdet aber ich zeige dukas drei meiner
lieblingsrestaurants hier in meiner
heimatstadt köln deshalb schaut da auf
jeden fall vorbei und das ist sowieso
verlinkt das letzte wort gehört dir oder
die letzten seite ja ich sage danke für
das leckere essen wie auch am anfang vom
video schon sagt ein tag persönlicher
koch sagt man sich schon immer mal
gewöhnlich ist wie man den genuss
gekommen ich hoffe ihr habt das zweite
mal wieder angelegt bis einschalten
würde war für katar